das kreuz in der frauen bergkirche
nordhausen entfernt er sorgsam von der
wand gesangsbücher und
alltagsgegenstände trägt er aus der
kirche schichtet sie fein säuberlich
draußen auf und stellt sogar stühle der
gemeinde ordentlich auf den vorplatz
versehentlich geht eine jesus figur zu
bruch auch die vitrine geht kaputt hier
räumt ein afghanischer flüchtling ende
letzter woche die st jakobi frauenberg
kirche im thüringischen nordhausen aus
denn der seit fünf jahren in thüringen
lebenden flüchtlingen ist der festen
überzeugung dass der christliche glaube
falsch sei und jesus nicht gottes sohn
ist beim ausräumen der kirche geht es
ihm wohl nicht um mutwillige zerstörung
der pfarrer der gemeinde beobachtet die
tat zufällig als er aus dem fenster
schaut stellt den 25 jährigen afghanen
zur rede und ruft die polizei
jetzt spricht pfarrer müller bei bild
wenn wir schnell feststellten
ausländischer mitbürger der auf eigene
kappe sozusagen hier angefangen hat aus
zuordnen das war schon erschreckend
zu sehen ich möchte man sagen das waren
schon religiöse hintergründe anders kann
ich nicht sagen weil er sagt das alles
hier das darf nicht sein das kann nicht
sein
das muss alles raus auch andreas
schwarze superintendent des
evangelischen kirchenkreises südharz
sagt es machte so ein bisschen den
eindruck wie einer entwidmung dieser
kirche die stattfinden sollte aber die
kirchengemeinde hat an der stelle gesagt
nein das bleibt natürlich unser
gotteshaus und wir tragen die dinge
selbstverständlich wieder nach drittem
am sonntag kehrt in der gemeinde langsam
wieder ruhe ein und der gottesdienst zum
reformationstag findet wie geplant statt
sandra hat vorhin gesagt was passiert
wenn integration nicht gelingt ja das
ist ein fall eines menschen aus
afghanistan der
2015/2016 hierhergekommen ist also seit
fünf jahren hier in deutschland lebt was
ist da schiefgelaufen
also das ist schon ein wirklich
beeindruckender religiöser anschlag auf
das christentum in dem fall nicht als
terroranschlag sondern als ein anschlag
wo jemand einfach auf raubzug geht in
eine unserer kirchen und einfach
ausraubt was er dort als unideologische
und christlich oder einfach mit seiner
religion nicht in übereinstimmung sieht
die kaputte jesus figur ist dass das
schlimmste beispiel schlimmste sinnbild
dieses religiösen anschlags das muss man
einfach auch mal so deutlich festhalten
ja was ist schiefgelaufen der
integration ich glaube es geht darum
wenn man ein land kommt zum beispiel
nach deutschland dass man sich
geflogenheiten die hier gelten anpasst
und dass es zuerst immer um diejenigen
geht hier herkommen sich anzupassen und
zu schauen wie lebt man eigentlich in
deutschland umgekehrt würde man das
glaube ich ganz genauso erwarten wenn
man beispielsweise als deutsch-deutscher
nach afghanistan geht und dann in dem
land versucht zu leben müsste man sich
dort gewissen regeln anpassen und wir
gehen hier eine selbstverständlichkeit
gelingt aber trotzdem nicht gelingt
trotzdem nicht das ist richtig dass wir
beim zweiten thema integration was läuft
da schief die frage ist ist so jemand
überhaupt
integrierbar und das eine frage über die
wir auch diskutieren müssen es gibt
viele viele menschen die nach
deutschland zugezogen sind und die hier
ganz prima leben die hier friedlich
leben die auch ihre kultur leben und
trotzdem das recht hier was ihr geld
akzeptieren aber offenbar ist jemandem
wie diesem afghanen das kreuz die bibel
die jesusfigur ein totales dorn im auge
dass er hier nicht toleriert und so
jemand hat in diesem land nichts
verloren und dann fragt sich natürlich
auch wie viele ticken vielleicht auch so
aber zeigen es gar nicht und dann guckt
ihr leuten ja auch nur vor den kopf wir
wollen noch mal ganz schnell schauen was
auch der spd landrat matthias jendricke
gesagt hat er sich wegen des angriffs
auf die kirche auch entsetzt zeigt es
war ein gezielter angriff sagt er auf
unsere christlichen werte die meisten
von ihnen leben unsere kultur ab es ist
ein irrglaube zu denken sie würden sich
gut integrieren wollen
tja wir schaffen das der berühmte satz
von angela merkel einer der
die hängen bleiben nach 16 jahren angela
merkel haben wir es geschafft
also das ist ein zweischneidiges schwert
wenn man solche bilder sieht und diesen
vorgang hier dieses afghanen der eine
kirche in thüringen
ausraubt weil ihm die symbole nicht
passen weil er diesen glauben ablehnt
dann haben wir natürlich nicht geschafft
aber es gibt andere ich kenne selbst im
bekanntenkreis beispiele bei denen hat
die integration ganz wunderbar geklappt
die sind ebenfalls geflohen im jahr 2015
nach deutschland gekommen und arbeiten
jetzt hier in ganz anständigen berufen
beispielsweise im friseurhandwerk in der
gastronomie also das sind menschen die
auch ihren eigenen lebensunterhalt
bestreiten können die ganz hervorragend
deutsch sprechen und die sich hier ein
neues leben aufbauen und wir brauchen
wir auch genau die geflohen sind aus
politischen gründen aber die das leben
so wie es hier deutschland ist
angenommen haben mit all seinen rechten
seinen pflichten aber auch seinen
schönen seiten und auch dem genuss den
man hier erleben kann und den dingen
also das heißt die sind integriert zu
einem teil oder mehr oder weniger gut
das kann man schon sagen aber es gibt
einfach schwarz und weiß und ganz ganz
viel genau dazwischen und das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen